Did you hear there's going to be a big anti-fur rally downtown today?
Anti-fur rally? What is that all about?
You know, people are against killing animals.
Oh, well, I agree with that.
Maybe I should go to the rally.
Sure, why not?
It's going to be in front of Blumenthal's Department Store.
Blumenthal's? Why there?
Because they just signed a multimillion dollar deal to import expensive rare...
...furs from Russia.
Oh, I see. Then I guess that's a good place to hold the rally.
I heard even the mayor is going to be there.
He's going to make a speech, too.
He must feel very strongly about the issue.
He does. He is well-known to be a strong environmentalist.